okay then we start to get to these guys
so one too many I'm gonna put it on a
game that means a single x value will
give you multiple y values when you put
it in right so for example if you get
one X too many Y you can get anything
that looks for example like I'm gonna
draw a weird-looking thing like this
Zoop okay now if you turn your head over
just turn your head over the way I drew
this was this is kind of like a cubic
right this is a quadratic this is kind
of like a cubic right except I've turned
it over on its side right now the thing
here is if I pick a single x value let's
get my green again if I pick a single x
value clearly like pick one like here
you see that guy it's like which Y value
does that correspond to you and the
answer is lots of values right in this
particular case is three of them right
so I've got one up here there's a second
one I've already collided with there's a
third one over here okay now when you
get your vertical line and you run this
across right let me just extend my graph
a teeny bit you remember I mentioned
before the vertical line test is
something you've got to pass everywhere
on your graph not just on a few spots
it's got a pass everywhere so even
though I put a vertical line here you're
like cool I pass over here right as I
move across and I have to test the whole
thing you're like BAM no good right the
fact that there's too many even if it's
not everywhere it's just somewhere right
the fact that it's too many at least in
some places means we've got to the
vertical line test do we pass nope we
fail okay so well this guy does anyway
so with the vertical line test it
doesn't work and as you can see up here
that disqualifies it for being a
function right last one down here just
for the sake of completeness cuz I'm
really trying to emphasize here right
what - what is x - y input to output
many X's will give you many Y's can
anyone think of the common example shape
that we had sorry yeah the circle the
circle is the classic example right go
ahead draw a circle for me
right so you can go ahead you can slap
your vertical wire across that it
dramatically fails in dramatic fashion
okay if you pick a single x value like
here right it corresponds to multiple y
values like so but it also works in
Reverse if you pick a single Y value
it's also going to correspond to many
X's like that okay so you can see what I
was looking at with this vertical and
horizontal lines so it's like I'm just
intersecting everywhere okay so this guy
here it does not pass the vertical line
test so we no longer call it a function
we call it a relation right and it is
actually important all of these things
here so I'm going to draw us you drew a
really big long curly brace right all of
these things they are all called
relations but functions like a special
kind of relation right so they're all
relations like so it's a little bit like
squares and rectangles if you like right
every rectangle sorry let me start that
again every square is also a rectangle
it's like a special version of a square
right and these guys don't stop being
relations any more than a square stops
being a rectangle these are functions
but these guys are not so they're only
relations okay now just on the board
here's a couple more things on to point
out before we leave off just so we've
got our review all in one spot this is
talking about the vertical line test I
know that some of you will have
encountered a thing called the
horizontal line test some of you will
have not I'm deliberately not talking
about that right now because the
horizontal line test is kind of
irrelevant to what we're focusing on at
the moment has to do with this thing
called inverses which we're going to
worry about later it's its whole own
thing so that is why it's a conspicuous
absence from here I remember when I was
learning this the first time and it's
really easy to confuse these two if you
learn them simultaneously and there's no
you know pressing need to lose the
horizontal line test you're not going to
get anything useful out of it whereas
right now the vertical line test is
telling you whether these things are
functional and that's something we
really do want to know okay one other
thing and this is something that misses
this is going to get onto a little bit
later see this very
the one-to-one right I happen to draw a
graph that started low and it went high
and it just sort of does that all the
way it's really important that it like
never turns back around because if it
did turn around don't draw this but if
it did turn around why would it not be
one-to-one what would it be instead if
it turned around at some point which one
of these would it be exactly right if it
turned around at some point any point it
would become many-to-one
because there are several good morning
several x-values like these two which
correspond to a single Y value so it's
no longer one-to-one before I come to
your question rest I'll just make this
quick point what that means is to be
one-to-one you've either got to keep on
going up all the way and never turn
around or alternatively and actually
this is worth um drawing line if you've
got a different color just sooner
confuse things this is going up all the
way without ever turning you could also
have something that's like going down
without ever
sorry that's a pen that's what they're
without of attorney do you see that's
also one-to-one like with any x value
you can only find one y value for it so
we give this guy a special kind of name
right we call it monotonic which is
exactly what it sounds like right when
you hear someone and they're speaking in
monotone and they never have any up or
down bits in their voice because it
never goes and changes it's always
monotone it's always the same right so
this is always going up always going up
never turning around or always going
down it's monotonic like a person with
no tone in the voice okay or no changes
in their tone I should say if it's going
up and this is very original right we
call it monotonically increasing because
that's what it's doing it's going up and
if it's going down it's monotonically
what do you think not increasing
decreasing right so like I said maybe
you want to write them here but we're
going to address this a little bit later
on so it's monotonically increasing or
it's monotonically decreasing less than
you had a question before what did you
what is it okay good